welcome my talk miasma cosa Gomorrah I'm
gonna be going through how we've been
combining computer vision and NLP for a
multitask fashion attribute modeling at
shop runner so for starters what is shop
owner and shop runner is a chicago-based
ecommerce company which essentially
partners with around 140 different
online retailers we represent thousands
of individual brands and historically
the core business offering at shop owner
has been free two-day shipping and
returns
yes very much like Amazon Prime but more
recently we've been starting to develop
more data product style offerings to
help expand our partner retailer
capabilities and first a shop runner we
have kind of a specific definition for
attributes so I just want to go wanted
to go through that here for us an
attribute is a characteristic of a
product that it can be applied across
multiple taxonomy categories and a
taxonomy category at least in my brain
is kind of something like a section of a
department store so you have women shoes
men's shoes women's dresses handbags
those are all examples of taxonomy
categories then on the other hand we
have attribute categories which are
things like color and patterns so things
that can be applied across these like
different taxonomy groups then before we
go on the diagram on the right is kind
of something I've sprint I've sprinkled
various ones throughout this
presentation is a bit of visual flair
but I call these my sample attribute
feeds and essentially these are things
that I've generated as parts of
presentations internally at shopper nerd
or product managers basically the idea
is that rather than trying to convey to
these folks like oh here's an accuracy
score here's a F beta score where beta
is 0.3 these don't really mean that much
to them and in order to get visceral
reactions out of them I found it useful
to sort of generate these feeds because
at the end of the day what they care
about is being able to generate clean
feeds in our app and website so a shop
runner it's important for us to able to
standardize these attributes across our
product catalog because of the way that
we kind of act as an aggregator for like
these 140 retailers and these 140
retailers can send us attributes or sort
of descriptions of their products in
whatever way shape or form that they
choose so one retailer may send you
fairly like what sounds like vanilla and
simple colors although color is super
complicated they may send you things
like white black blue red orange so very
simple but you might have another
retailer which takes a much more artsy
artful approach and say oh we're gonna
send you
like ivory cream obsidian dust grozny
midnight blue velvet these are all
things that we have in our catalog and
basically these attribute models provide
us a way to audit sort of in a very odd
like automated way to normalize our
entire several million product catalogue
without having to rely on like manual
mappings which is what folks have done
in the past the other area where we want
to apply our attribute models is as
feature extractors for other services
that we're building so one such example
is kind of visual similarity in search
we're trying to find similar items in
our product catalog so the overview for
this talk we're gonna go through two
main areas so the first of which is this
exploring our network architectures so
I'm going to go through kind of the data
choices that we made the overall
structure and methods that we used and
then kind of into the individual image
NLP and then the ensemble models the
next what the next part of the talk is
going to focus on kind of some secondary
interesting problems that we've come
about that we had to basically solve
because of the way that our attribute
modeling is working at shop Runner so
instead of having the sounded like one
list of attributes which would be super
practical and super easy to build a data
set for and market what we have is an
ever-changing ever-expanding number of
attributes so we need to be able to very
quickly add on a new attribute and
deploy it so we need to figure out some
things way to figure out about how to
maintain the weights of our models from
previous runs so we don't throw out a
lot of useful ABI like previous effort
and then figuring out how to physically
train that and for that our team ended
up building out a fairly novel multi
task multi data set training pipeline
and then I'll just close out by saying
where we're at and where we're going so
start with the network architectures and
a fun feed of like Paisley's psychedelic
things so for and for our products we
really have like two main sources of
data so there's that as images and text
and when we look at it and think about
attributes you can think that images you
have multiple images per product and
these images convey certain attributes
particularly well so things like color
and pattern on the other hand you have
text so this is product descriptions
titles brand sizing information and
using code other sorts of attributes
particularly well so sleeve length
sizing and cuts are example of that
and if you think about it these are
these text attributes are ones that the
images actually have a hard time
conveying and vice versa so what we have
here is two different sorts of data
which provide different perspectives on
our products so they make good
candidates for building sort of larger
ensemble networks the other reason why
it's good to have these sort of
different perspectives or like different
types of data and different models is
because sometimes we just get products
where the data looks weird for one of
these two inputs so this is a product
pair of jeans where you can see it's
blue you can see the cut you can
probably like pull out other attributes
from that but if you look at the text
the Texas had some weird characters
inserted into it which might be enough
to throw off a solely text-based model
on the other hand we have another pair
of jeans where the but in this case the
image is fairly nondescript it looks
like a handkerchief napkin tablecloths
Howell take your pick but in actuality
what it is it's a very expensive pair of
Fendi designer jeans from Italy but we
wouldn't really know that just looking
at the images so now we talk about the
data I'm going to go into sort of our
architecture style of choice and if the
title that talked didn't give it away
it's called multitask learning and the
idea here is that we're basically in a
try and you get a network to
simultaneously optimize to solve a bunch
of related tasks simultaneously and
looking online sort of one of the fun
ways that I saw this described he was
using a pop-culture reference to Karate
Kid so in Karate Kid you have this group
of antagonists called the Cobra Kai and
they're basically went to school yard
bullies who've learned karate is a form
of violence they basically use it to
beat people up so for them karate is
about fighting but when you look at the
Karate Kid in contrast when he learns to
fight from mr. Miyagi mr. Miyagi doesn't
teach them how to fight mr. Miyagi
teaches him us a bunch of seemingly
unrelated auxiliary tasks so things like
waxing a car painting a fence standing a
walkway and what the karate kid doesn't
realize is that these tasks are while he
thinks that are pretty dumb but what
they're actually doing is building him
up both mentally and physically so that
when he learns to fight he actually has
to fight at a very high level in fact
he's able to fight better than the Cobra
Kai he only specialized in fighting like
using karate as a way of fighting so
stepping back some of the things that I
mentioned there are talked about and
like
metaphorical example with multitask
learning is that explicitly it acts as a
form of regularization within your
neural networks and what happens here is
that an network is basically penalized
in training if it tries to over
specialize into a single hypothesis or
single idea basically in the network has
to take a step back find a more
generalized hypothesis to explain all of
the different tasks but it's looking at
and then be able to solve them all at a
fairly high level so far for us at shop
runner we have these varied problems so
things like try to predict pattern style
and color and these varied task follows
in the similar fashion domain and
technically we could train up individual
networks to solve each of these problems
but each of those networks would likely
be learning similar things so the
hypothesis that our team had going into
building out these attributes was that
if we can build a single network that
trains these multiple tasks
simultaneously we could kind of share
the lessons learn on each individual
task and build up the model to like a
higher level than it would be otherwise
so a trap runner we kind of do a
specific type of multi task learning
called hard parameter sharing and the
idea here is that you have some core
model it's gonna be an LST M and RN and
any type of neural network or any pre
trained model you can think of and
really what we're going to do is take
the features from that network and pipe
them into individual task layers and
these task layers are the ones that will
be doing the classification work but
because of the way that this is set up
these tasks layers are actually sharing
like 99.9 percent of the weights in this
network and that's sort of what allows
this network to share context across
these various tasks and Bill don't have
more generalize understanding of your
problem space so what happens in sort of
training is you kind of feed a sample
through and for each task you get their
scores and you calculate their losses in
a very like standard manner but you kind
of need this unified batch loss in order
to I guess bad coffee back propagate
through the network and get it to learn
and when I first started in this area I
thought that sort of getting this batch
loss would be actually very complicated
but when you read the research papers
and kind of put it into practice
something that's very effective that
people try to make sound much more
complicated you literally just add them
together and this is the extent of the
math and write presentation but so once
you add these together you can actually
just use that aggregated batch loss as
like basically to back propagate through
the network and this is how
network learns so one sort of issue of
that theoretically you can run into here
is that you might have one loss that is
much higher than the rest and we haven't
personally run into that at chop runner
yet but are keeping an eye out for it
and the solution that you see in
research is basic just to normalize the
weight normalize the losses into more I
guess normalized range so before I dive
into the number of architectures I just
want to talk through kind of our general
training protocols for all of these
networks and in general what we end up
doing is we when we go to train a new
attribute or train a new model we
randomly initialize the new layers we
freeze the weights in the Train sections
of the model and then once we freeze
those sections we can then go ahead and
aggressively train the randomly
initialized sections and typically these
these new sections won't get up to
state-of-the-art but they'll get up to a
good enough point such that when you
unfreeze the network and then train
everything in a very low learning rate
you have the network kind of gel
together and get to it's kind of higher
performance and for the learning rates
at this final stage there's a number of
different ways that you can assign it so
one way that has become popular because
of like rise of fast AI and a lot of
those courses has become to assign
learning rates and kind of a gradient
from least trained to most train or
something that I end up doing a lot in
training is just to assign different
sections of the network different
learning rates depending on how trained
it is so now I'm going to go into the
sort of our image architecture and our
the current version our image model
takes two inputs so it takes a full
product full image of a product and then
like the center crop of that full full
image we then feed those two images one
by one through a resonant 50
architecture and then extract the
features out of the final layer so these
are two lengths 2048 vectors that we
concatenate together to get that 4096
vector that we then feed through a final
dense network and the idea here is that
we can take the sort of large feature
vector and condense it down using the
dense Network which we can then pipe
into these final task layers and in this
architecture kind of the fun interesting
part is that the fact that we decided to
use these cropped images in our final
deployed model and it was motivated
because early on our data science team
was kind of brainstorming problems that
we will run into with this like actually
modeling pipeline and something that we
thought is that we're actually losing a
significant amount of information when
we go and take these retail like high
quality images and
sighs them down to the 224 by 224 for a
resonant type architecture so we're
losing kind of the detail context
information which could be useful for
certain attributes so one solution we
came up with was if we can find a way to
re-inject that context information it
might be able to boost her performance
and something that we settled on was
taking a shot using center crops and for
me the center crop thing is kind of fun
because it's not motivated by my
experience as a data scientist so much
as a previous career where I work as a
photographer so for me or like basically
any photographer when you start learning
how to do photography you're regardless
regardless of who you learn from or what
style you're learning something that
gets indoctrinated into you very early
is this idea of the rule of thirds so
you basically draw a tic-tac-toe board
so these vertical horizontal lines and
you basically try and place obstacle of
interest on these lines or the
intersections of these lines but when
you apply this kind of early
indoctrination of photography style into
like a fashion domain what you get are
very standard looking pictures such that
if you look at cross like this even the
small subset where you have outdoor
images indoor images sort of shirts
dresses pants
you still get like if you look at that
Center box you're basically getting a
good center of mass shot of that product
most of the time so adding the center
crops is actually pretty easy to do and
it boosted the performance of our model
by several percentage point across our
attribute categories but a downside of
this method is that it is pretty simple
and pretty dumb so it doesn't account
for things that don't fall into that
kind of style so when we have certain
retailers which take more artsy
approaches to their images sometimes
they get Center crops that aren't
actually effective so in order to
mitigate this weakness things that our
team has been working on is really doing
a lot of clothing detection type sort of
fine-tuning models to in-house datasets
with the idea that if we can use these
bounding boxes as a pre-processing step
for our attribute models we're almost
guaranteed to get a good center of mass
shot of that product then the next step
we're thinking about is doing
segmentations of fine-tuning these
models to basically use the binary mass
generated by them to kind of take a
product out of an image and place it on
a white background such that we can get
a very apples to apples comparison to
kind of things in our
cataloger and things that the model
would have seen during training so now
I'm going to go into sort of the NLP
part of the model architecture so for us
the text fields that were using are
things like product name description
brand and whatever other sort of
information retailers choose to provide
and we're basically feeding this into a
bird architecture and I'll go into more
details about what Bert is but for all
you have to know for right now is that
it's a very large architecture which has
been very good at an NLP type task and
we take the features out of Bert and
pipe them directly in a series of linear
task layers so this architecture looks
pretty straightforward which it is but
it's kind of motivated by what other
folks have been doing in the field so
for instance there was a group out of
Microsoft who published a architecture
called Big Bird so yet another strange
Sesame Street name for an architecture
but essentially what they did is they
found they could get state-of-the-art
results just by training bird in a multi
task fashion and then allow and
basically because of the multi task
training it has to learn to generalize
better than a single task bird model or
there are some other groups out of
Stanford who are doing similar work
around multitasking bird architectures
so Bert as an architecture was released
at the end of 2018 by Google and while
most language models have been trained
are trained in kind of a using the left
side context of a sentence to predict
the right next word what happens in bird
is you're it basically takes in the
entire sentence and in training and mask
out certain words and uses the left and
right side context of that word to kind
of predict the mast out one and Google
found this to be a robust training
methodology and like other language
models that's trained on large corpuses
of data so all wikipedia plus whatever
other data sets Google had on hand at
the time and really it and the other I
guess language models that have come out
over the past year year and a half our
facilitating this kind of very fun
imagenet type moment for the NLP field
and what I mean here is that
historically have been hard to apply a
state-of-the-art NLP architectures two
industry problems because most people
just don't have as much data as Google
Facebook or Microsoft shockingly and by
publishing these kind of weights and
making them open-source it means that
practitioners in the field such as
myself and take them and basically
fine-tune them to industry tasks very
quickly and as sort of some
implementation notes for
or the Burton architectures that we're
using a shop burner currently it's
maintained by a group of called hugging
face out of France is another
interesting name and their library is
called pipe or transformers it's super
cool if you haven't had a chance to look
at it and are looking for a way to kind
of track an NLP problem because they
built out ways to sort of lit load and
so save these part Wars models they've
built out the tokenizer so you don't
have to worry about how to pre-process
your data for these different language
models and really they can be trained up
like any sort of standard PI torch model
so if you have existing pipe lines you
can actually integrate them very quickly
and get a model up and running in a very
short period of time so now get into our
ensemble so ensemble is really going to
be taking kind of the architectures and
kind of smashing them together so we
have our inputs that we look at for the
ensemble so it's a full image the
cropping the crop image in the various
text fields then we're basically gonna
pipe the respective data data points
through the their respective models and
instead of having those output final
task layers we're actually just going to
take the final feature vectors from each
of those models and can Nathan together
and feed them to another dense network
with the idea that this dense my worker
is really going to be doing the heavy
lifting to go line the knowledge at
least two models and feed them into
these final task layers and essentially
what we've found with this architecture
is that we've been able to Train it on a
number of attribute or ease and expand
the number of categories and that it has
continued to perform well and so in like
the worst case scenarios for certain
attributes we get the highest score from
the respective model and but typically
we get a several percentage points over
sort of either model individually so
it's these models are typically becoming
greater than the like sum of their parts
so now I'm going to get to the sort of
problems that we had around expanding to
new attribute categories and because of
the way that it's a never you we have
this ever-growing ever-expanding list of
attributes we had to think carefully
about how to maintain the weights from
our previous runs so basically make sure
we didn't throw out a bunch of effort
because in simple terms we just try and
force some architecture or weights into
a like a slightly different shape
architecture you're I guess a deep
learning framework we'll probably throw
a bunch of weight errors at least I hope
so
and then the if you weren't careful and
kind of like slice up that dictionary of
weights and try and force them into an
architecture it might work it might not
and one of the worst-case scenarios I
found while testing this is it actually
worked but then I was getting different
predictions out on the like when I fed
samples through so we just had to be
very intentional about the way we did
that and then this problem how to train
new task heads and really what our team
was looking for was is there something
better than we can do there are very
traditional data science pipeline where
we have a single data set and our
training up a single model to predict
the categories in that like data set
because realistically we'll never have
that data set and it's hard and
expensive to maintain and constantly add
on to that those large data sets and
then it's sort of some subjective side
quests that we had was to keep our model
count down because our team does all of
our own deployment and maintaining of
our models it adds a significant burden
to our team if we're suddenly gonna
deploy like 30 attribute models and
monitor them in production so I think
all this weight maintenance process my
Franken model process and the team
hasn't accepted it or rejected it yet so
we'll see we'll see what happens in the
future but for now I'm going to take you
through sort of two rounds of attribute
modeling so in this first sort of
spinning up a new attribute model and
training it on say three tests what
we're gonna do is some nice bookkeeping
and we're basically to say these tasks
one two and three we're gonna mark them
as new classifier layers and then we're
to go ahead and train it you can tell
it's trained because now it's colorful
and essentially what we're gonna do with
this process is now that they're trained
we can mark these classifier layers as
pre trained or fine-tuned and what we're
going to do is prepare to save them and
we'll save the core model sort of as
separate weight files so out of this
architecture and training process we end
up with these two files correspond in
two different sections of the network
then what happens in a subsequent round
where we're gonna add on kind of graft
on this new task for on to the previous
architecture so in this example the core
model task one two and three are all
actually the same structure but you
can't directly load in the weights
because it is a different shape than the
previous one so what we're gonna do is
basically mark task 1 test 2 test 3 as
pre trained classifiers task 4 is gonna
be a new classifier because we haven't
done anything with it yet and then using
these two weight files that we had
previously we're basically going to
start slotting them into their
appropriate sections in this new
architecture because of our bookkeeping
so now what happens is we have this
architecture where the core model tasks
one two
three are all pre-trained and you
maintain the weights from your previous
run so now all you have is this task
form new classifier there that need
really needs to be trained up so you go
through do the training mark them all as
pre trained and then you can once again
save them and at this point you can
basically use these weights and load
them into an API deploy them and hit
them in like production in fact
absolutely fine then when you need to
add on the new tasks you basically just
repeat this process so next step is now
that we can add on these classifier
layers and kind of adjust these
architectures and expand in your
attributes we had to figure out a good
way to train it and what our team ended
up doing is we kind of made this a
fairly novel multi task multi data set
training pipeline so like I mentioned
before that we were trying to figure out
a way to avoid those very traditional
data science pipelines where you have
this single data set because in our
point of view you can have this kind of
like one data set to rule them all that
has all of your categories marked in it
but for us because we have to keep
adding on things we run the risk of
adding a new attribute and then this
data said we've been sort of coddling
and nurturing it may not actually
represent that new category well which
means that we then have to basically
build a new data set mark both sides
with all the respective categories join
them together which is a very
time-consuming and arduous process if
you're having people to basically hand
label hundreds of thousands of rows all
of the time so for us we thought okay
what if we can take a step back and try
and envision a world where we can train
multiple data sets or each data set is
essentially tailored to an individual
category and this means that we could if
we can do this it means that we can
train up a new attribute
simply by getting getting a data set for
that respective category and then very
quickly we can go through and train it
up and get it into our pipeline so when
we were doing this and took a
significant amount of like R&D time from
our team but once we got it going it's
actually a fairly streamlined process so
I hope you think it's interesting as
well
so for this example we'll train up a
three class problem so say we have color
pattern and style and what we're going
to do is to prepare these data sets and
whatever way makes sense for those data
sets or whatever your framework sort of
entails and when you get when you get to
the point where you're generating the
batches
what you end up doing is you actually
take the batches from all of these
datasets and kind of throw them into a
grab bag and randomly shuffle them then
what happens is in training you take
this grab bag and you draw out of this
bag without replacement and you feed
each batch one by one through through
whatever architecture you're trying to
train so in this case we'd route a color
batch we feed it through our model we're
actually going to get at the output
probabilities from color pattern and
style but since we this is a color color
batch and it's only actually marked with
color you only calculate the loss for
color and use that color loss for back
propagation then on a subsequent
iteration in this epoch you basically
say you drew out a pattern batch once
again you're gonna feed it through the
model it's gonna output probabilities
for color pattern and style but because
it's only marked for pattern you're just
gonna calculate the pattern loss and
kind of the idea here is that we can let
them network predict whatever it wants
for color and style but because we don't
have labels for it we're not gonna
penalize the network for decisions and
makes on those categories and this kind
of training cycle ends when we get to I
guess you draw that left final batch out
of that grab bag and it causes the
training epic and when you after you
train up a model in this way it's kind
of interesting because the model at no
point has seen a sample which has been
marked for color pattern and style kind
of all together but what you get is
performing a sort of model that performs
as if that had been the case and it
means that we can really add on new
categories extremely quickly and all we
really need to figure out is the most
clever way to build that dataset so kind
of just wrapping up and really using
these methods so their architectures and
the sort of tips and tricks that we
built out to kind of expand the
attributes we've been able to add on
additional attribute categories we've
trained with multiple data sets and made
sure to test like situations where we
had unified data sets for multiple
attributes and kind of train them up
both pipelines to see how they compared
and we found that our like multi data
set approach to basically get the same
results so that was good
also train them up on a number of
domains to make sure this wasn't
something that just weirdly only worked
in fashion so that was also good to hear
and we found that these at these sort of
architectures that we've built out and
continue to perform well across new
categories as
adding them and some the ongoing work
that we have is really around trying to
incorporate these actually models into
more services that we're building so the
team has been focusing on things like
visual similarity and we found that
incorporating these attribute models as
feature extractors on the back end for
these similarity services actually
improves their performance significantly
and then additional areas where we're
trying to incorporate them going forward
are things like in the wild product
search so the idea that users can submit
photos and we returned similar items in
our product catalog then we have style
personalization and outfitting is kind
of additional horizon type Rd things and
of course because it's a problem that
never ends basically we're just gonna
keep expanding the ad number of HP
categories for these models in shop
runner so that's my talk and questions
and for I guess some context this is our
team data science logo at shop owner
initially it submitted just a horse that
had your name drew in his deep learning
lecture as our like potential mascot but
our director shot it down
so I basically put a plug on top of it
and he loves pugs so that got approved
and yeah contact info so questions
so currently we have like five
functional attributes we started with
two earlier than the girl in the year
have been incorrectly adding on three oh
I guess I forgot to repeat the question
question was how many attributes we have
so right now we're only up about five
four or five fifth ones being built down
now so it's been a slow to sort of like
get traction and how to build out all
the processes that go into like data set
building and then getting these like
pipelines working so hopefully we can
get up get up speed and keep start
adding on attributes at a quicker rate
so that's kind of where we're at now yes
so essentially we're not really labeling
anything in our like image searches
right now so something we're just taking
them taking the feature vectors out of
them and using like basically comparing
the similarity of the feature vectors so
that's kind of like where we're at now
we're not redoing any labeling and
storing of stuff so
oh sorry can't hear you so right now
we're the ideal situation would be
earth-like so okay so the question was
when we add our new attributes we freeze
the weights in the previous sections and
the ideal for us would be yes but we've
had some issues getting the new task to
train up those sufficiently high level
while holding everything frozen the
network so we've been kind of forced to
Train things are very low like very very
low learning rates and like the main
sections of a network to get it to gel
appropriately but yes the ideal
situation would be if we can just hold
everything frozen because then we don't
have to worry about how like now the
models were deploying or slightly
different from the previous versions
that we had in like our like production
so yeah that's something that we're also
kind of struggling with and dealing with
right now in the back
oh let's see so question was something
that surprised me in this pipeline
trying to think I think it's really been
how hard it has been for dataset
building because a lot of the fashion
topics oh it's like even for simple
things like color and pattern it's super
subjective and very kind of arbitrary so
you have to be very careful and how
you're building these datasets because
decisions made very early on and that
pipeline basically just snowball subside
you can actually just destroy the
categories that you have in your final
model so if like when we got started we
actually did do several iterations of
color and pattern which are kind of the
initial ones we scoped out because we
basically tried to get hand laid like
hand labelled images from like a using
figure 8 and basically we got very low
quality and a lot of cross contamination
from those datasets so when we did like
just initial kind of RNG we just got
terrible color categories and terrible
pattern categories and didn't know what
to do with it so we kind of have to like
burn it down and start from the start
from scratch so yeah
yeah so I think before I joined up the
team was using a lot of like fast AI but
then when I joined and started doing a
lot of multitask stuff we found that
like fast AI doesn't support a lot of
our needs so we ended up building out
kind of a custom PI toward framework to
do the multi dataset multi task training
and that's kind of something that our
team is hoping to open-source we're kind
of working to see like which sections
are appropriate and what we can actually
do because it's kind of a nifty way to
solve this type of problem although
we're actually unsure of how many people
have this problem so who knows but we
are trying to like open source the
useful sections of the frameworks that
we built built out see any other
questions cool yeah feel free to talk to
me or contact me however always happy to
chat
[Applause]